hey everyone its Mike wattles and I'm
inviting you to join me on Tuesday
September 19th at 2 p.m. Eastern Time
where I'll be speaking at the investor
inspiration online trading conference
along with five other traders each of us
will be discussing what works for us in
the market best of all it's free to
attend and for you to watch just go to
the link below in the description or go
to http / / www or foes com / signup dot
HTML and the lineup for Tuesday's
investor inspiration conference is
starts out with Aaron huntsacker Dan
Passarella then Jason Levitt myself at
2:00 p.m. then AJ Brown and Matt Buckley
now what I'll be discussing in my
presentation is how to improve your
trading discipline with the order flow
the top mistakes traders make and how to
avoid them how order flow will keep you
on the right side of the market and I'm
gonna show you how to discover a trading
edge that can make you a consistently
better trader you know after all that's
why you know you should attend these
these investor inspiration online
conferences is because you want to
become a better trader ultimately right
and by becoming a better trader you're
going to lose less money and make more
money ideally that's the goal right and
if you could get one little piece of
information that can transform your
trading then it's definitely worth it
right and again even if you can't attend
register and at least you'll be given
access to the replays when they're
available now again you know myself I'm
an order flow trader this is an order
flow chart and it looks intimidating but
it's really not there's a lot of great
information on this chart as opposed to
just a normal bar chart if you're not
using an order flow chart you really
should consider it and I hope you can
attend my presentation and I can convert
you over into looking at the market
through a microscope and understanding
what's happening in the market I don't
say microscope more like an x-ray give
you x-ray vision into what's happening
in the market and find better trading
opportunities that's what you that's
what you want to do that's what's going
to give you an edge in the market so
again you know brief disclaimer our
presentation is for educational
informational purposes only should not
be considered a solicitation a buy or
sell a futures contract or making any
type of investment decision futures
train contain substantial risk and it's
not for every investor an investor could
potentially lose
more than the initial investment risk
Apple is money that can be lost without
jeopardizing one's financial security or
lifestyle only risk capital should be
used for trading and only those were
sufficient risk capital should consider
trading past performance is not
necessarily indicative of future results
so you could sign up now for free go to
order flows calm slash sign up at HTML
or click click the link below in the
description there's two links one will
take you you could sign up through my
website and the other one will take you
directly to the investor inspiration
signup page so thanks and hope to see
you there on Tuesday bye bye